SINCE THATA
PHYSICAL, HARD-HITTING GAME, THE
AVALANCHE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
B
HE RANG IT OFF THE INSIDE OF THE
BY HATHAWAY INTO THE CROSSBAR.
>> NATHAN
HATHAWAY UP BUT NOT OUT.
HAVE SEVEN GAMES TO
GO INCLUDING THIS ONE.
SLOT AND FLIPPED IT UP AND OUT..
EACH TEAM NOW WITH SEVEN SHOTS T
POINTS IN PLUS SIX.
THAT'SS BY AUBE-KUBE
TURNOVER.
MacDERMID A COUPLE OF BIG HITS
IN THE LINE-UP TO MAKEENT GUYS
SCORING THE GAME-WINNING GOAL.
>> LOOKED HAS BEEN A THOT A STI.
BACK IT COMES INTO THEHE AND THT
ON THE AVS' BENCH, LOGAN
O'CONNOR..
SCORE. PUCK.
HE BEATS THE AVALANCHE DEFENDER
TO THE PUCK AND POKES IT HOME.
OW, THIS IS A CLUB THAT'S BEEN
SCORING A LOT OF GOALS.CATCHING.
I DON'T KNOW HOW IT GOT THROUGH,
BUT IT DID.
>> MOSE, HERE IS A NUMBMBHE POSO
THE LEFT OF DARCY THATMMERED DON
THE AVS HAVE TIED THE GAME AT
2-2. RIGHT HERE.
DID HE GET THE P
THE CAPS WANT TO CHALLENGE IT.
AND THEN PUSHES THE PUCK?
>> COULD BE.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO WE'LL LET
REFEREE OVER GETS IT AND
TURNS.
UP THROUGH THE
NOW.
FACE-OFFS BECOME REAL BIG.
THERE'LL BE A LOT OF
.
THE AVS GOT CAUGHT A LITTLE